just told me there is an email from
martina about
feedback about this conference so you
can
praise the speakers complain about the
organizers or do whatever you want
our first speaker is ronald dan
from the water institute and right now
is
just writing very slowly his title
just uh as a spoiler let me tell you
that this title
uh combines three major scenes of this
workshop
first low concavity second
concentration of measure and third the
discrete hypercube
and all in just one ticket so ronan
please go i didn't know the hypercube
was the same
so it could be yeah
glad to hear that okay thanks
uh then i guess
just let me start this is joint work
with uh
freddie keller omele chameleon and
offers a toonie
and like in overview
this talk is going gonna be about we
know that
log concave measures in r n
are concentrated and
we want to find an
analogous notion of low concavity on the
discrete
hypercube and prove concentration over
there
as well this is the topic of the talk
uh so let me just start by reminding you
what happens in rn so this is
going to be the motivation for us
so uh rn
so here's a fact
suppose that i have a measure in rn
with a convex potential so suppose that
d nu is equal to e to the minus v
dx nu is a probability measure
so nu is a
normalized to be a probability measure
and v
from r n to r is uh
i wanna i wanna make it uniformly convex
meaning i want to require that the
hessian of v
is uniformly bigger than some
positive constant delta times the
identity
uh then
this is the fact this is implies
several uh concentration
uh several ways in which this measure
is concentrated let me describe them in
like
an hierarchically increasing way so the
weakest type of concentration
you can consider is the following so for
every
one lip sheets
test function phi
from rn to r
we have that the variance
with respect to nu of phi
is at most one over delta
okay this is probably the weakest type
of concentration you can think of
then there's a stronger one where you
can actually say
something about higher moments and this
thing is actually exponent
it's basically sub gaussian but i don't
want to get into that let me just
formulate a slightly stronger type of
concentration in the form of a poincare
inequality
so for every
smooth enough
phi we have again that the variance
with respect to nu of phi
is now bounded by one over delta
times the expectation with respect to nu
of the gradient of phi
squared so this is called the poincare
inequality
and then we we really have
an even stronger thing for example a log
sub 11
quality
which is the same thing where i can also
add a log
so okay let me actually
let me not write what this is if you
don't know it it doesn't matter so much
in this talk we'll be mostly talking
about this
and this type of concentration okay
and now i want
to ask a question actually
let me before asking the question let me
formulate this fact
a little differently it's not going to
matter so much
but let me say that dnu
is e to the it's just going to be more
convenient
a bit to say that it's e to the plus
v and here i'm going to write d
gamma where gamma is the
standard gaussian measure
and then instead of asking for the
hessian to be
bigger than you know delta times the
identity
i changed the sign so i really this is
equivalent to saying that the hessian
with respect to the gaussian is at most
one minus delta times the identity
right because the hessian of the
gaussian is just
one so when i wrote this now i didn't
really change anything still the same
fact
but it's going to be more convenient
because now i want to ask you know
what if i replace gamma
well what if i replace rn
what if our n becomes
the discrete hypercube
and gamma becomes
mu which is just defined to be the
uniform measure
okay so the reason i
one of the reasons you know it's it
pedagogically makes more sense to
to write gamma here is that you know
with respect to gamma even if v is just
you know equal to zero everywhere we
still have concentration
and also if you know here v
is equal to zero everywhere we still
have concentration with respect to the
uniform measure on the hypercube
right so it makes more sense to compare
the hypercube
to the gaussian rather than to the
bag measuring rm right this is a measure
that already has
some curvature in some sense
okay and we're gonna face
uh several challenges
when we try to uh you know
take this notion and adapt it to the
hypercube
because there are several real things
it's not clear how to write
in the setting of the hypercube first of
all
it's not clear what one lipschitz
functions
are going to be second of all
it's not clear what
the right analog of this thing is going
to be
and maybe let me change this
a little bit and let me just copy it
here and
just mention that in the setting of
gaussian space or rn
the right hand side here is also called
the dirichlet
form usually denoted by
this fancy e
of phi and phi so this is just defined
to be the right hand side
one over delta okay
uh so it's also not clear what the
corresponding
notion of a dirichlet form is going to
be let me
write it like that and finally it's
clearly not clear
what you know the analog of this thing
is going to be
right any questions so far
just you know to give you a taste and
and convince you that things are not
going to behave
the same for example in gaussian space
if i take the gaussian measure and just
condition it on any convex set
i still get to keep my concentration i
only get something which is more
concentrated than before
but on the discrete hypercube you know
conditioning on a convex
subset is like conditioning on any
subset
you can always take the convex cell it's
not going to change anything
so clearly you know things are not going
to be as well behaved
in gaussian space okay
so here are some
here is one result and this is going to
be the first
so case one is going to be
uh just the case of quadratic potentials
so here new dnu is going to be
e to the v d
uh the uniform measure on the hypercube
and v is just going to be and v of
x is just going to be some
x a x for some matrix
plus some vector h
dot x in gaussian space
this is a very easy case because we're
always going to get
another gaussian measure but on the
discrete hypercube
i guess uh most people here know
that for some matrices a it's very very
hard actually to understand what the
behavior
of this measure is going to be
okay and
i mean in particular it's not even clear
how to understand what it's
what the covariance structure of the
measure is going to be
and maybe an example to keep in mind
is the so-called
sharington kirkpatrick model
or spin glass which is just the case
that
we take a i j
to be a gaussian
centered with variance 1 over
n or actually
beta over n where beta is some constant
so beta is uh of constant order
uh okay so
here there's already a very nice result
which i should first mention by
uh so the first theorem is by
bowel schmidt
and bodino
and they show the following so they show
that if
h is zero
if there is no external field and if the
operator norm
of the matrix a is
at most one over four
then we have a poincare inequality
of the following form so
let me just see that
i remember it correctly
um
why don't they have it here
okay then we have
the following thing so we have that the
variance
with respect to nu of any test function
phi is at most
uh n
over the operator norm of
a sorry
over 1 over 4
minus the operator norm of a
times and
now i have to tell you you know what the
analogy of this thing
is so it's just going to be
written exactly the same as here it's
just
going to be the expected gradient square
and the gradient is just the discrete
gradient so it's just going to be
the expectation over new
of the gradient phi square
where what is the gradient of phi where
the this the i discrete derivative of
phi at
x is just defined to be
phi at
x where the ith bit is
chosen to be 1 minus phi
at x where the eighth bit is
minus one over two
and the gradient of phi is just defined
to be
you know del one phi
up to del n of phi
okay so this actually looks uh
this is a very nice result it actually
has a
an amazingly short and nice proof
uh one yeah it has to be psd
right ah yeah yeah
sorry uh
yes the way this is formulated a has to
be
psd note however yeah so
right let me just write it a
is
a positive thing but it actually doesn't
matter
so much because we can always subtract
an identity from a
all right it's not going to change the
distribution
so you know what this is saying is just
you know instead of
psd we can just say if the operator norm
is at most one over eight
then we can always make it psd and have
the operator norm at most one over four
so it doesn't really matter so much
uh so one drawback of this result
is that if we go back here
to the to gaussian space
this this dirichlet form
implies mixing for you know longivan
dynamics so it's
actually useful to prove that
concentration of this form because then
you can for example sample from the
measure
using a random walk however
to this dirichlet form in the discrete
case
there is no corresponding discrete
time dynamics
which you know this implies the mixing
of so actually
in the discrete case it's more natural
to consider a
slightly different uh type of uh
dirichlet form which corresponds to the
so-called cloudberry dynamics
so um
so the global dynamics is just defined
as
a markov chain such that the transition
probability from x to y
is the indicator that x is a neighbor of
y in the discrete cube
times uh the measure at
y over the measure at x
plus the measure at y
maybe let's normalize it by one over n
so you know this just corresponds to
generating a coordinate uniformly
conditioning on all the other
coordinates and then you know choosing
the value of this coordinate
according to the conditional measure and
then to this
dynamics corresponds
the dirichlet form that looks like this
so mu of x
p x goes to y
and then just
phi x minus phi y
squared
so is this a sigma just making sure
yeah this is a sigma sorry yeah i don't
know my
handwriting is yeah
any other questions uh
so arguably this is a more
natural dirshley form than this one
in the context of the discrete hypercube
and
the first theorem uh
with a killer
and say tony
is basically the same thing but
for this uh cloudberry dynamics
and also
with any magnetic field so
uh we basically have a poincare
inequality
of this form so for every phi
we have that the variance with respect
to nu
of phi is at most
almost the same so n over 1 over
4 minus the operator norm of
a times
the dirichlet form
so in particular a corollary is
that global dynamics
mixes in poly time
uh for high enough temperature on the sk
model
ah good question clema um
so clemai is asking is there something
conceptual about
this one over four
yes there is a reason one over four
appears but first let me
just say that this is not the critical
temperature
so it's expected that this fact is true
not
up to one over four but up to one half
actually but
one over four is when we have
that uh so you know this
this is not this is for any a this is
not
only for the sk model and actually one
over four
is the phase transition when you
consider
rank one matrices so if you take rank 1
matrices
in the all one's direction you will see
that
like 1 over 4 is where you have
so so this this result is actually sharp
but it doesn't
imply a sharp result for the sk model
okay good so this was
uh the first result but i actually in
this talk i want to focus
more on another results
which i forgot so the the operator norm
is the inverse of the temperature
the operator norm is equal to beta
factor one half
so usually in when you define the sk
model
you have one half here in the exponent
and you have minus v so
yeah so so if the inverse temperature is
beta then beta is
uh twice or
one hold on yeah
beta i think is twice the
operator norm in this language
so this is up to like
one half of the critical inverse
temperature this works
okay uh so you know this was only for
uh quadratic potentials and now the
question for quadratic potentials it
kind of makes sense you know
to define log concavity
uh so you you can still do it like this
but when the potential is not quadratic
then
you know it's not clear at all how to
define low concavity because the
potential is only defined in this case
on points of the discrete hypercube okay
and okay now the question is how do we
what's what's the correct notion of low
concavity
so
[Music]
i want to suggest one notion which will
give
a non-trivial concentration inequality
and this uh the definition has to do
with the so-called
uh multi-linear extension of a function
on the discrete hypercube so let me
remind you that
for a function f
from -1 1 to the n to r
there exists
a unique way so there exists a unique
function
f hat which is
a function from uh
you know the 2 to the power
n to r such that
i can write f as a multi-linear
so for every x f of x i can write it
as the sum over all subsets
of 1 to n
of f hat of a times this
product over i in a x
i
right this is called the fourier walsh
expansion
whatever
and another way to think about this so
so
i'm calling it a multi-linear extension
because you know this function was
defined on the discrete hypercube
but the right hand side really makes
sense in all of rn
and not on only that it's a harmonic
function
in all of our n and also it's a harmonic
function
in in the relative interior of every
facet
of the discrete hypercube so you can
instead of a multi-linear extension you
can think about it as a harmonic
extension
if i have a function defined only on the
corners here
then you know i can extend it
harmonically to
edges and then extend that harmonically
to two dimensional facets etc etc
until i get a function in the whole you
know
solid hypercube so
so this formula basically gives away
this gives away
to make sense
of f in
minus 1 1 the interval
minus 1 1 to the n right and by the way
you said
already harmonic extension but now you
gave us different dynamics
on the discrete cube
i didn't give anything ah yeah
well harmonic you know i'm just harmonic
with respect to the usual laplacian in
rn
right i didn't you know i didn't
connect this to any dynamics yet
good point though ronan uh
okay this related to lova's extension
this version of
uh i actually don't know what you refer
to by the lava
extent but you know i
i guess in in most papers you will
open on boolean analysis you will see
you know this notion
ah good so you know it doesn't make any
sense to
ask about the low concavity of f as a
function
defined here but as a function defined
here
it already does make some sense to ask
about log concavity
but on the other hand it's pretty hard
to find low concave functions on like
when they define what they are defined
like this
because being both harmonic
and low concave those are two things
which
are pretty hard to satisfy together if
you think about it
right because like if you're harmonic
it means that you know the hessian
as it has traced zero but on the other
hand we want you know all the eagen
values of the asean to be
negative so low concavity would be
a way too strong thing to require
i mean we basically get an almost empty
result
luckily in gaussian space recall that
we didn't need our measure to be low
concave we just wanted
to wanted it to be not too long convex
because the gaussian measure already
gave us
some low concavity and
you know ideologically the discrete
curve the discrete hypercube should also
give us some low concavity and indeed
that is
what happens so we we're not going to
ask for low concavity of
f but we're going to just
ask for semi low concavity so
we we're going to define so
the measure
nu is
going to be called beta
semi log concave
if
d nu is e to the
v the
the uniform measure and
the hessian of
the log of v
is bounded by beta times the identity
and beta can be positive
and when i and and this you know the
left hand side here means
first take v consider the multi-linear
extension
and then take the hessian of the log so
this is
you know so this is
at x for all x
in the solid hypercube
okay and here's
a theorem
uh if mu
is beta semi
log concave then
for every one lip sheets
and by one lip sheets we mean here you
know one lip sheets with respect to the
discrete
derivatives we defined before so it's
just
one ham in clip sheets for every one lip
sheets phi
we have that the variance
with respect to nu of phi
is at most n to the
2 minus some constant over
beta where c is a universal constant
and let's let's
look at the right hand side here for a
second
linear functions with respect to the
uniform measure have variance
n so we definitely can't get
anything better than n here
okay on the other hand
n square for one liter functions
is just an empty result because any
any one lipschitz function has
oscillation at most
n right the diameter of the hypercube is
n
so any any lipschitz function has
variance at most n square
so what this is saying is basically you
get
some non-trivial improvement over what
you have
if you know nothing about the measure
so for example if you think about the sk
model in low temperature
it's not going to satisfy this in low
temperature
if you if you think about spin glasses
then
the ver you you can find one lipschitz
function
such that the variance is going to be n
squared
at least one sorry is better at least
one
um so you know if
beta is uh
i mean it works for every beta
ah but then can you i didn't tell you
what this c
is so we cannot take better to zero
[Music]
yeah you are right um
yeah you're right beta has to be bigger
than uh
than c yeah
good point
okay so uh you know this is
this is the weakest type of
concentration you can think of but it's
still
like a first step towards some notion
of low concavity and sorry for a stupid
question
do you really need the log in the
definition of the
better lung concavity
semilog concavity um
i mean no i mean without the log it
would
i think the definition will be yeah
but you have been the in the power
right so i'm i mean uh you're asking
will this be true if like i define it
without a dog
just a need to pick just a little it's
not a question
what what what if you look at if you
look at the one line above
the new is e to the power of v d mu now
log of v
is not something that makes much sense
for us just to remove the log
no but he he wants v to be bounded by
something away from zero
so i think it's correct
i mean it's correct the way it's written
now but i'm i'm
i'm just not following so much what
you're
suggesting i mean i think this is the
i mean okay first of all you know i'm
taking the log of v
not only on the hypercube i'm looking at
the log
on the entire like extension
so so so i don't want to say
extend v inside i want to extend
e to the v inside and then like
does it make sense not too much
x squared like yeah sorry sorry sorry
sorry
i said yeah i see i see i see what
you're saying yeah yeah yeah
um you don't you just you just want to
get rid of the log there
right right right right right right
right yeah yeah yeah
so
this is what i want okay yeah yeah
got it now
uh good yeah sorry i confused you now
now it's correct
i'm taking the the actual density i'm
extending it inside
and then i'm looking at you know the log
good yeah um
okay so let me just one remark
that this is related
to some recent very nice results
by uh
annari
[Music]
and vincent
so what they do they also consider
uh some notion of low concavity
for uh probability measures on the
discrete hypercube
but they basically look at first of all
they look at homogeneous measures
and they find some notion of low
concavity which is
not invariant with respect to
reflections
so for their their notion somehow
they have a very like the direction one
one one has a
you know is it has a special
importance and i don't want to write
exactly what they know the notion they
consider
is uh they okay i'll just say in words
they consider the so-called
characteristic polynomial of the measure
and they want it to be a log concave
at a certain point and also they want
all its derivatives
to be low concave and they get some
poincare inequality
for these kinds of measures so
i think you know so it seems like there
is some relation between those two
results but what they do is like their
proof is like much more algebraic
and what we do is like
the both the notion and the proof
is like much more analytic oh
sorry i also forgot to say this is
joined with
uh omel chamil so this is
so you know just for for those of you
who know these
series of results it's interesting to
compare them
but it seems that you know the relation
is more superficial
even though they do have some low
concavity
involved there okay
so um any questions about this result
if there are no questions i do want to
open
in with your result related to the
previous result and also to
to the case of product measures where f
is exponential to a linear function
i see so for first of all for product
measures you know you don't i mean
you already have concentration pretty
easily
because the inequality is tensorized
the question is whether you become
whether you get the same result here or
you already
suffer because uh ah i i already do like
this this never gets all the way to n
so it just gives some improvement
but it's definitely it it doesn't get
all the way to one and it definitely
does not give up one calendar quality
it only gives concentration for
lipschitz functions
we didn't try actually to push it
much further we were just looking for
you know
some kind of concentration for the more
general case
so it definitely doesn't recover what we
had before
thank you
uh okay so let me try to give you some
ideas of the proof
in the time i have left so
so since you started five minutes
clearly also every five minutes
[Music]
so how how long do i still have it what
does it mean
to ten minutes ten minutes okay great
so okay
so i have this measure new on the
discrete hypercube and i want to
try to explain to you how i can use
its you know this low notion of low
concavity
and the first step so step one
is going to be the following so it's a
reduction
to uh
something like you can think of as a
small transportation
between
tilts
so what do i mean by that
um
[Music]
let's define so for any measure nu
let's define tau sub
w of new to be the measure whose density
is like the density of new but
tilted in the direction w so i want d
of t w new at x
to be defined as e
to the w dot x
d nu x
over the integral of e to the w
dot y d nu
y so you can just think of it as taking
the measure nu
and exponentially tilting it in you know
the direction w
okay and
step one is going to uh
to do the following reduction so
suppose
that for all
w in rn and for all
unit vectors theta
we have
that the
wasserstein distance which i'll define
in a couple of seconds between
the tilt
w of nu and
the tilting direction w plus
epsilon theta of nu
epsilon is small
is at most some constant
where w1 between two measures
u1 u2 is just defined to be
the supremum over
all one lipschitz functions
of the integral of this with respect to
of you know this difference
which is also you know the cost of earth
moving
with respect to the hamming metric
between nu1 and u2
so suppose that if i tilt my measure in
the direction w
and i tilt it in a direction very close
to w
then i know that i have a good
transportation plan between these two
measures
then
new satisfies the
concentration
as above
i'm not going to explain how to
prove this step but i am just going to
say that
a very similar idea appeared in a paper
of
boaz
probably 2008 or something
i think
uh in the context of low concave
measures
in some vague way
um
pretty vague way i guess but i mean if
you'll see the
proof this is not so so vague so
let me just say that this this this
notion
is somewhat related to
something called the h minus one norm
of the measure okay so this
i i think this step is like more
standard in analysis so
i don't want to you know i don't i don't
really have time to explain it so much
but this this property that you know if
you tilt the measure a little bit
you don't get something very far away me
i i do want to give you a little bit of
intuition of
why this is related to concentration so
suppose i have some measure on the
hypercube
let me draw the discrete hypercube like
this
which is on this side of the hypercube
it's concentrated
here and on this side of the hypercube
it's
concentrated like in the antipodal
direction when
where i think of this direction as being
one dimensional
and this direction i'm thinking about it
as you know the rest of the dimensions
so this is like
an n minus one dimension
in this uh sketch okay
so suppose that you know if i change
this coordinate from minus one to one
then the center of the measure changes a
lot i mean
in this picture it only changes by one
coordinate but this one coordinate think
about it as
you know many coordinates
then this is not concentrated the the
the picture i i did here because you
know these
two pieces are very far away from each
other
and the and this non-concentration is
going to be demonstrated in the fact
that if i tilt the measure a little bit
in this direction
then all of a sudden this point
gets more measure and in order to
transport it
back to the original thing i have to
move mass all the way from here to here
which costs a lot
okay so somehow concentration
can be reduced to the fact that if you
like push the mass
in some direction then moving it back
doesn't mean you have to go in a
diagonal way
but you can kind of go in straight lines
okay this i i i don't
know if you like this intuition or not
but this is the best thing i can give
you
unfortunately but now i wanna
talk about step two so step two
and this is how to prove a fact like
this
and how do you prove a fact like this so
actually
there's an a very nice stochastic
process
that gives gives the gives this almost
in a straightforward way
so let's
define a stochastic process as follows
let bt be
a brownian motion in rn
and let me define
uh okay let me first
write uh a stochastic differential
equation
so consider the stochastic differential
equation
w0 is equal to w
and dwt
is equal to dbt
plus the gradient
of log f
which is the harmonic extension of the
density
at wt dt
so i just recall that d nu
was f d mu
okay so you know this this thing
makes sense and
um
yes hold on sorry sorry sorry
something is
no not exactly sorry um
yeah okay let me just
call this a sub nu of w
t dt and a sub nu is not exactly going
to be the gradient of log f but
almost so i'm going to
define f of theta
as the log laplace transform
of the of the measure and u so this is
going to be
the integral e to the x
theta d nu
of x
log and i'm going to
define the vector a sub nu at
w to be the gradient of
log the gradient sorry of
f at w
okay so now these equations are
are all well defined
okay and
a nice fact is that
if i look at a sub nu
of w t
and i take its limit so
it's not very hard to see that a sub nu
is
always going to be in the convex hull of
the support of the measure so it's
always going to be in
-1 1 to the n
and if i if i take this limit to t
equals to infinity
then this is always going to converge to
a point
so this is going to converge to a point
to
some random variable that
let's let me call it x and this is going
to have the distribution
nu sorry it's going to have the
distribution of
tau sub w of nu
i know this is a lot to follow in the
last five minutes of the talk so
you know you don't need to understand
all the equations
only or the the only thing you
i i want to kind of uh i want you to
take from here
is that there is a natural stochastic
process
which samples from the measure new so
you know this stochastic process lives
in rn
but if i invoke this function a sub nu
then it converges to a point which
samples from
tilts of the measure nu is there a
natural way to write this backwards in
time
because uh
probably yes but i
can't you know i'll need to think in
order to understand how
only because this one is hard to couple
with the measure that samples
from you know it's hard to couple
different w's with this notion
i mean maybe it's not but no i mean it's
it's it's not
yeah so right so so you've you're one
step ahead of me
so now you know i want to consider
two tilts so it's actually pretty easy
to couple
couple different w's you just basically
take
the same brownian motion almost
so you know this this gives me a way to
sample from
every tilt of new and in order to say
that
two tilts are close in transportation
distance
then you know it's enough to find the
coupling such that
you know the two end points are close in
transportation distance
and the whole point is i know i'm out of
time
so let me just say it in words the whole
point
is that the way we defined log concavity
exactly corresponds to the fact that
this function a sub nu is
lipschitz i mean it's a lipschitz vector
field
so i can actually start from two
different
tilts run the process and couple them in
a way that they don't get too far from
each other
very fast so just by considering
low concavity and you know using it in a
straightforward way to analyze you know
two coupled versions of this process
i can just immediately prove like the
the type of transportation inequality i
showed you before
so let me end here but i hope i gave you
some taste of you know what's going on
in the proof
thanks lenin for a brilliant talk any
lecture any
questions to learn well we have time for
one quick question
well then don't you need to to control
the longevine dynamic all the way to
infinity in order to get your
transportation
that's true but uh
it's not very hard to see that the
derivatives of this fund
like the second derivative of this
function becomes very very small
as time increases so in in some
sense the the right way to look at this
is
you know reparametrize time
exponentially
like if you if you just take the uniform
measure you see that
this thing becomes small exponentially
i see okay thank you
okay um any other questions
um okay so thank you again on n
and let's meet again it in five minutes
which is
1005 plus 1005 pacific time